[Musik]
hallo herr james sallis ich war schon
lange nicht mehr auf diesem sofa um mit
euch zu erzählen und zwar gibt heute ein
neues baby update rennella ist immer
noch ein baby würde ich mal so einfach
behaupten oder das letzte update ist
wirklich schon acht monate her und es
ist unglaublich wie schnell die zeit
vergangen ist und wie schnell die kleine
maus groß geworden ist und es ist so
viel passiert in letzter zeit also ich
muss euch jetzt acht monate in ein paar
minuten wieder geben und erzählen ja was
die kleine maus alles gelernt hat kinder
lernen hier wirklich jeden tag wasser so
und ich habe euch ja auch versprochen
diese beikost video zu machen problem
war einfach ella ist so schnell
gewachsen und es kam alles schlag auf
schlag auf schlag
viele videos gedreht und es ging einfach
nur die wolken beikost aber das bekommt
wirklich versprochen ein video und das
wäre dann extra anreiz und ja es 14
monate als im oktober haben wir ihren
ersten geburtstag gefeiert und ich weiß
noch beim alten wg update als den neuen
monat habe gerade das krabbeln gelernt
ich glaube jetzt auch wieder hochgezogen
aber laufen konnte sie nicht und es ging
dann alles furchtbar schnell das heißt
nach dem video hat sie bereits
angefangen zu laufen aber ich glaube mit
elf monaten konnte dann wirklich schon
freilaufen und familie war genauso
schnell war das weiß noch und wir haben
zum beispiel jetzt noch freunde wo die
erhebung im gleichen alter noch nicht
laufen und es ist auch völlig normal
also die erwarte einfach besser so
schnell finde ich auch und ich finde
auch wenn wir laufen können sind sie
irgendwie keine babys mehr geht es die
ausnahme stellte alles andere bands
durch die gegend und macht alles
unsicher und irgendwie ist er doch auf
dem babyalter vor aufgewachsen schon mit
elf monaten gerechnet gibt dir mal 17 17
kindergeld ausgerechnet technischen und
die zinsen auf und war im camp auf
packungen dagegen rechnen und dann bis
leider ein minusgeschäft
vielleicht das geschäft mit kindergeld
ja und ich stelle sie seit dem 17 monate
altes nicht mehr und war einfach perfekt
irgendwie so noch quatsch gemacht hat
und dann habe ich hab mir kommt das
lassen wir einfach und habe sie
abgestellt obwohl ich mir gerne
weitergespielt hätte was ich dazu sagen
aber wir haben ihr dann die flasche
gegeben an parametern milch gemacht und
es war dann auch für der punkt wo sie
angefangen habe durch verschlafen und
das fand ich sehr schön denn dann hatten
wir auch mal ein paar ruhigere nächte
verwaltungsrat habe mich ins bett gelegt
und hat einfach geschlafen und es war
wirklich sehr schön und ich muss sagen
so mit dem schlafen haben eigentlich
wenig probleme der leute ja genau
abwägen
viele zähne bekommen das heißt die
zählen forderungen noch die eckzähne und
jetzt in den letzten zwei wochen hatte
so ein paar mal macht probleme
dafür dann wurde dann wirklich jede
nacht jede stunde aufgemacht ist aber
das war einfach den zähnen geschuldet
dann kriegst du einen schnupfen husten
bekommen fieber bekommen aber das war
wirklich nur sehr selten
ansonsten muss ich fragen ist die ella
eigentlich pflegeleicht also man kann
sehr gut beschäftigen sich sehr aktiv
nach vorne zu fahren als aktiver
alarmierend ist onkel aktive anfang ist
auch ob ist in geschult weil in
geschützte geschwisterchen dabei tut dir
immer andere sahen ihr hoch zelaya dem
ist sich auch verbissene mit er uns von
ihrer kümmert sich sehr liebevoll um
ihre schwester muss man echt sagen ist
eine ganz tolle große schwester die auch
sehr vernünftig mit ihr umgeht gut
manchmal ist diese grob also ich muss
manchmal sagen von mira villa ist keine
baby born
also du kannst nicht einfach an den
führten packen und runter hängen lassen
im kopf bleibt ihr wahrscheinlich aber
deutlich gemacht selbst sagt das hatte
beim europa gesehen na ja er macht dann
ab 20 tagen wiederum geht ja mein gefühl
hat mich um die stadt gebracht und dann
abgehauen und alleiniger super hinteren
gretel wir ab du armes kind aber habt
ihr das geschafft
christus hat auch beim uba und die zwei
machen das wirklich super
wir machen bei drehtagen zb so da machen
wir dann morgens auf die kinder fertig
mache ich mich fertig dann wird
gefrühstückt meist und wenn die raketen
kindergarten und enercon koma
denn das problem ist wenn die ella beim
dreh mit dabei ist dann hinter alles
aufeinander
die nimmt an kisten und töpfe und steigt
drauf geht auf die arbeitsfläche und
nehmt einfach den ganzen haushalt
auseinander
ganz klar wir wollen schon mal gezeigt
bei videos eher wie kabel früh steigt
und rumkommt wir haben ansonsten spricht
sie schon und verwerter gefährt an mehr
als mama papa ist die famila oder sagt
mathiak ihrer japanisches lieblingslied
haben und war kira kira akhavan und
gepflegte absolut ruhig essen trinken
windelwechsel spielen dann muss man
einfach fan die nehmen und nicht stehlen
was sie ist und so wahnsinnig wir müssen
sogar stoppen also was ist es eher
lustig klingt ist aber extra die ist so
viel und stoppt nicht dass sie sich
danach übergibt
wir hatten nur aus mitleid lang er hat
nur liebe geben rheinmetall alle morgens
beim frühstück da kriegt sie meist müsli
und esslöffel selbst auch schon selber
und probiert es dann mit dem löffel
hinzukriegen
danach gibt's leberwurstbrot das ist ja
auch gerne geflügel leberwurst und ja
man muss sie aber stoppen denn wir
hatten eine zeitlang das problem dass
wir abends wenn dem bettler kannst du
noch diplomatisch getrunken und dann hat
er angefangen zu rufen um sich zu
übergeben und wir dachten sie hätten
magen darm infekt oder es irgendwie
krank verschleiert aber es war einfach
hat einfach zu viel gegessen und was
dann kam eben wir daraus es wird es aber
auf hatten ging es dagegen in zwei
wochen zum trinken nur eine
wasserflasche seine bisschen aber das
war's dann auch schon
ja auch nur beachten sie die zähne
bekommen das heißt jeden abend jeden
morgen werden die zähne geputzt machen
ein bisschen schwierig ist beim thema
selbermachen
aber man weiß bei kleinen kindern die
kriegen das selber nicht hin also muss
man dann selber nochmal nach puppen und
das will sie natürlich nett also sich
immer ein kampf ich muss immer inne
haben und auch uns zunge raus und es ist
sehr schwierig aber ja
kinder hat habt ihr auch schöne seiten
libanese superschön
wir müssen auch sehr viel lachen mit der
lh also momentan kletterte überall hoch
es ist sehr gefährlich sind auch
mehrmals am tag auf dem kopf ist
wirklich gefährlich aber die kletter zum
beispiel schon alleine in den stoffen
stuhl und da muss ich dann immer also da
muss ich immer sehr aufpassen
das müssen wir auch immer verbieten weil
wir dann auch einfach rein fallen und
lief er ist immer gut gegangen aber nur
muss natürlich immer dabei sein und ihr
auch ein bisschen helfen aufmachte noch
wenig hier hinten weg exoten und stellt
auf dem boden machte übereinander und
dann kann er auf die arbeitsblätter
übernahmen den aufsteller müssen wir
immer hinten lassen weil wenn der ob
stelle hier auf dem wohnzimmertisch
steht dann beißt sie jeden apfel an
wirklich jede nacht über nicht einen
fetten anbeißen zurücklegen anweisen
zurücklegen oder wie mandarine machte
sich die von friedemann layer genau
genau sein und dann könntest du
ausdrücken bedrückt dem doktor 80 so
witzig was machte noch gerne von ihrer
hat so eine turnmatte so eine grüne und
die breiten die man gern auf und da
könnte dann halt macht sie gern
purzelbaum hat die bei mir gezeigt und
das hat er im schaukelpferd das hier das
ist auch richtig löst das hat uns ein
zuschauer geschickt aber der papa von
der zuschauerin und wir haben die
schreinerei und das ist wirklich süßes
hat dann dieses pferd für die ella
gemacht extra in pink und weiß nun vom
lieblingsfarben und was schaute super
gerne und holz wirklich komplett aus
holz und das macht ihr super viel spaß
germany made in germany 114 echt schön
was macht ihr noch mal ich haben wir ein
bild mit ihr zusammen gemalt sind halt
so die kinder wachsen sehr schnell und
vom irak kommt dieses jahr in die schule
ich habe schon in der schule angemeldet
und habe noch gedacht ach gott es ging
echt super schnell die zeit die wir
dieses jahr schon sieben jahre als und
deswegen muss man erinnerungen
festhalten und auch ella wird es ist ja
schon freie radio und dann habe ich mit
den beiden ein porträt gemacht und zwar
haben wir eine leinwand genommen und mit
fingerfarben haben die kinder dann hier
drauf gemalt
hier seht ihr auch ein paar fotos von fr
mal aktion
also wirklich mit vollem körpereinsatz
elano in tampa und hat dann mit den
fingern rom gebracht
hier ist zum beispiel sanierers
handabdruck hier ella irgendwo noch
fußabdrücke und dann haben wir das bild
eingeschickt und die liebe coni hat dann
die porträts von den beiden drauf gemalt
und das ist wirklich super schön
vor allem finde ich ist auch eine tolle
geschenkidee ich habe zum beispiel einen
gutschein gekauft und den meiner cousine
geschenk zur geburt ihrer tochter hatte
auch zwei töchter und kann jetzt auch
eben demnächst irgendwann mit der
leinwand von bild machen und habe eben
noch schöne erinnerung
habt ihr richtig gut getroffen wo ich
stelle sie ab jetzt auch viel schönes
krieg den er im klub ja antworten muss
wieder alles sehr aufpassen das heißt
wir können keine terrassentüren offen
stehen lassen denn energie vertraut
spielt mit den steinen steckt in den
mund deshalb terrassentüren sind bei uns
immer verschlossen
außer wir sind eben aktiv mit dabei und
weil türen in der auf der toilette
badezimmertür müssen auch immer zu sein
denn sobald ich hier mal offen steht
wenn zum beispiel morath die tür nicht
gemacht also ich denke immer dann rennt
wie kleine rein und und in die klobürste
machte klose mit vollem letzte mal als
sie entdeckt habt da war sie in der
toilette drin oberkörper drin und habt
ihr mit dem wasser geplanscht und
gefühlte waren wohl in der luft und das
macht er halt super viel spaß das ist
der wahnsinn gesehen sobald die bücher
offen steht oder auch wieder rein oder
wo wir bummeln bei seine cousine hinaus
haben sein ford auf dem klo die probe
genommen und überall flogen gericht
kennt weiß auch nicht woher meine mama
fragt auch hier muss auch immer
badezimmertür abschnitten bei denen wir
nämlich die türklinken weiter und wie
kriegt selber die tür auf und ein paar
bartstoppeln gemacht also dass die für
schwer aufgemacht furchtbaren aber du
musst immer aufpassen wie steigt hier
auf dem esszimmertisch und man muss
immer dabei wenn man nicht hört dann
passiert genau das ist immer dabei sein
und auch hinten
schüsseln aus dann geht's in die
abstellkammer beim lebensmittelfarben
aus allerlei schon ein kleiner
wirbelwind aber sehr luftig man hat
immer was zu lachen
irgendwann will ich finde ich wenn ich
sie mir von ihrer auf barbies spielt da
schmeckt wie immer drauf und freitags
dann immer oder neurosen list genommen
hat und diesen an die mahnungen an gott
ja da wird man ja das foto das war ja
ziemlich lustig machen
geradezu bisschen aufregung so lustig
ist auch bilder fällt anfangs kannst du
das spiel ja sag mal hier was vor allem
gemacht dass ich jetzt auch gerne den
moment aufgenommen auf kamera wurde vor
in der kirche singen aber war leider zu
gefährlich sind einfach momente war
lebensgefährlich kann muss das machen ja
ansonsten was gibt's darüber zu erzählen
sie ist wirklich sehr gerne aber morgens
mittags abends zwischendurch immer mama
mama und bringt auch viel und wird auch
alles gemüse karotten zwiebeln alles ist
alles wirklich alles anders und ganz
aktuell und oliven fabriken bis also ist
all leben auswählen auf dem
frühstückstisch oliven haben und wir
immer oliven auf dem frühstückstisch
müssen wir erst mal verstecken vor der
weil sie kommt nichts anderes messen
will ausprobieren und bei mir aber stark
da haben wir ihr die oliven einfach mit
kern gegeben und die hat im mund wird im
kern auf passiert und ausgespuckt
das heißt wir müssen träumer den kern
aus polen die entwicklung ist ganz liest
dann sage ich einfach nur immer
geldpolitik selim also komm wir machen
und dann rennt schon auf die toilette
und danach nimmt er auf ihre windel und
schmeiße war in mülleimer hat in den
windeln und machte so warm und vor
mechanischen wir haben jetzt hier nur
ein kinderzimmer und viele fragen ja
kommt die airlines bei samira ins
kinderzimmer oder warum schläft noch bei
euch und bei sanierer ist hat die kommt
jetzt in die schule und wir wollen hier
einfach jetzt nicht mit uns immer geben
weil sie wirklich alles auseinander
nimmt die steigt auf ihren schreibtisch
drauf und verreißt machen und da wollen
wir einfach verlieren die privatsphäre
lassen sie auch verdient hat weil ihre
schwester mal ans wirkung nach hand und
jb
danach kommt bei mir ab und zu und finde
ich auch ganz schnell da kommt auch und
dann geht aber im raum genauer bringt
drei frau dem backcover wird
rausgeschmissen sachen soll schließlich
nach draußen langsam so viel liebe ich
gar nicht gewohnt aber ich finds es weil
irgendwann kommt die kinder eben nicht
mehr
wir haben aber er kann nicht so ins bett
weil die westens lange schlafen die
strecke dann auf pflicht und zieht mir
an den haaren und das thema und tritt
dann die wende sich und weltlich aber
playoffs sind beides musste ja bei uns
im kino finde ich ganz schön also
vermieter und auch laufend beide wege
offen und empfangen auf dem flugmarkt
herzlich also bei der lsv und partie und
feierten und freizeit immer mehr doch
damit verwechselt oder papa zwischen
papa kind ja das habe ich auch gesagt
ihr habt ja ohnehin häufig richtig ja
nebenbei dass mama und papa
kindermädchen kinder der papa anhängig
sagt meyer
ja stimmt dabei von ihrer absolut im
hinterfeld finden hier immer ärger sie
hat immer sie eröffnet aber auch noch
ihr regt aspekten fragen wo wir
angefangen haben will soll und
familientag im moment von mir leid sie
klagten papa kommt der wird nicht mehr
wachsen und dann versteht wird das sind
einfach in ruhe
wir haben ich glaube dass also wer
möchte machen wir gerne eben ein paar
wochen wieder ein kleines update das mit
der ernährung machen wir auf jeden fall
hatte wie wir mit ihrer bikes und
bereite angefangen haben und was immer
auch für tipps gibt gerade für kinder
die vielleicht nicht essen wollen weil
bei el arif ist wirklich ganz gut wobei
ich am anfang viel stress mit ihr hat
weil sie einfach keinen brei essen
wollte und ich eben erst auf die idee
kommen musste
okay wir dann doch eben den stick
reinbeißen es war wirklich stressig aber
da gibts einfach ein paar kleine tipps
und die kann ich euch gerne in einem
video weitergeben
genau so
und jetzt glaube ich haben wir genug
erzählt die sachen apple patent bei mir
noch ein kleines update die hat sich 90
einfach das handy geschnappt dem auto
und hatten wittler was erzählt und es
könnt euch jetzt mal anhören
also viel spaß dabei und bis zum
nächsten mal
[Musik]